foreign
an ax
I don't want to fight you then this is
gonna end quick
[Applause]
got eyes on Uncle muscle and the kid all
right everybody remember the plan
containing kidnap thank you
no no guns
alive
at least for a while
you ready
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh no you're good you're good okay song
lyrics stub toes Canon cars
moving to distance
[Music]
[Applause]
get out of there
[Music]
bloody
it's getting tricky guys I can't stay on
them for much longer
you remember my father
is
my father was a horrible man
very bad daddy
but I kind of liked him and you took him
from me when you stole our money he left
us with nothing but suffering
that's what I came up for
the end of suffering
oh and I didn't take that money
all right
I burned it
bloody
but he's in a black side prison off of
every map
and get her out
you would
so sorry but
what you're asking me to do is
impossible
foreign